hey guys Pete here gonna do my Q&A for
part three if you haven't seen the recap
and review you can check that out I'll
put a link at the top here and then yeah
I'm going to answer all these questions
that I got in the comments and the
lead-up to part 5 which is airing soon
first question is what was banging on
the door this refers to the mob zone and
I made a separate video about this that
you should check out but yeah the
actress who played brunette tells Cooper
that he better hurry because her
mother's coming so we assume that this
is what the noise is but there really
isn't any way to know for sure what
exactly is making the noise in the in
that video I made about the opening
sequence a lot of things point to that
noise being connected with what was
going on in the glass box in New York
City so I think it's fair to say that
that probably has something to deal with
it the creature that materializes inside
the the glass box and then eventually
kills Sam and Tracy probably is related
to that noise we're going to have to
find out more and your guess is as good
as mine if that's going to happen or not
next question was about that actress and
played ronette Pulaski and the commenter
asked if it had to be run at Pulaski
right well I don't know we know that it
is probably important that David Lynch
and mark frost decided to use this
actress for the steam but they made a
conscious decision to credit her as
American Girl and the closing credits so
it isn't necessarily the case that it is
Rona Pulaski now I also went into this
in the mobs own video and that's
basically where I'm at with it I think
it's important that they chose her but
I'm not sure why it's important the next
question was also related to the women
in that room and it was didn't the first
blind woman remind you of Josie well yes
and no it is a woman
an Asian woman and up until this point
Josie was the only main character who
was Asian but I don't really see a
connection between Josie and ronette
Pulaski not based on what we've seen so
far
I mean Josie died and seems to have gone
into some sort of supernatural realm
inside the wood according to her death
scene and last we saw run that she was
still alive so I don't know that there
is a glaring connection between these
two characters or that the choice of
using a Japanese actress here who had
who was actually in Inland Empire
another David Lynch movie is a definite
connection to Josie Packard next
question is how do you know the people
in the beginning are important and I
answered this in the comments as I don't
really but in the flow of watching all
four episodes in a row it seemed to me
at the time that it was more of a
courting scene of getting the real agent
Cooper out of the lodge more than
anything else
so these characters had a role to play
in that transaction but I didn't see
that as something that would be super
crucial beyond that function I could
definitely be wrong keep in mind I'm a
fan and I could always be wrong about
anything I'm not saying that I'm
explaining I see a lot of people make
videos saying that they are going to
explain what happened I mean good luck
with that if that's your thing then cool
but for me I'm just talking about what I
saw and how how I reacted to it and what
I thought and initially watching I
didn't think that these characters would
come back to be important you know play
important roles throughout the rest of
this run the next question was who
exactly is dougie and that is a great
question that there is no solid answer
for yet I made an entire video about
dougie as well and making that video
just brought up more questions than
could be answered in my you know my take
on it there's basically two options
dougie Jones is a person who existed had
a life a wife a child and somehow evil
Cooper
switched him with a different version of
it's a little bit confusing but you've
seen the episode so you know and the
other option would be that he never
existed in the world and that he was
just manufactured as Mike said to do
this decoy like bait and switch kind of
thing so that evil COO could stay out of
the lodge and therefore I can't really
explain how he has a wife a kid a job
you know all that stuff if you're really
interested in this I hope you watch the
dougie video and comment there
especially if you have any good ideas
about I mean like I say in that video
it's pretty obvious what his role is
evil coupe said he had a plan when he
talked to Daria that he was going to not
go back into the lodge and dougie played
a part in that but how he came into
existence is still quite mysterious the
next question was simply Garmin Bossier
stole a little bit off so I don't know
if that was a question as to say hey you
don't know how to say the word because I
did kind of must mess up the
pronunciation which a couple other
commenters pointed out or if they're
asking what it is quite simply Garmin
Bosnia is described as pain and sorrow
that Bob had collected he owed it they
seem to owe it to Mike in the arm and
that was delivered it is represented
with cream corn in our world and in well
everywhere I got so it doesn't
necessarily mean that all cream corn is
gamma musiah so yeah that's what it is
it's a it's a fuel as you will something
that does lodge spirits need Bob feeds
on fear and different things but he
collects Garmin Bosnia and then he has
to deliver it to the other people in the
Red Room thinking of Bob the next
question was what about Bob will he show
up this is another great question in the
mystery that has not yet been solved
what we do know for sure is that Frank
silver died in night
95 I believe so we will not see that
actor reprising the role however we did
get a shot of old footage with him so we
know that's still pivotal I mean the
very last scene of season 2 was us
finding out that bob was inhabiting
Cooper at the time and that all tied
into the idea that the good Cooper was
in the lodge and that he couldn't leave
so we start off this season 25 years
later at the point when he can leave but
that all gets mucked up that we saw in
these last two episodes so where we see
Bob I think that Bob is obviously has an
influence but it's not really clear
because well it's not clear if he if he
inhabits Cooper the same way he did
Leland Leland as a child invited Bob in
you know there weren't two versions of
Leland and Leland seemed to function
fine at times and then Bob would take
over so when we think about Cooper now
evil coupe he seems to be a blend of
those personalities he he's got the
skills of Cooper but he also has the
evil of Bob I'm sure that we'll learn
more about this but I'm not sure that
we'll ever know for sure how this is all
working or what's happened in the last
25 years but I can't wait to learn as
much as I can because like most everyone
else I have been waiting that long
wondering what was going to happen with
Cooper now that bob was inside of him
does Laura have a doppelganger well when
I'm really sure about that either it was
somewhat revealing that the Laura we saw
talk to Cooper in present time just as
he was about to leave the Red Room may
or may not have been murdered was the
scene where she removed her face and so
that could be a doppelganger now this
original question was related to the
fact that Maddie came that was a soap
opera nod you know there was a soap
operas daytime soap opera at the time
there was a lot of that kind of stuff
that happened so whenever Frost and
Lynch wrote that they they were sort of
playing off that trope I guess you could
say and you know originally there was
supposed to be a third red haired bird
in season three before the show got
canceled
so I don't think that that's
doppelganger related it seemed like
Maddie had a family and she had an
origin but you know we don't really know
as I mentioned in the last question the
doppelganger from Cooper could be
because Bob inhabited him without being
invited in it could be because when the
Merle or someone else was destroyed and
then that left an empty vessel I mean
the possibilities are pretty endless
here no the doppelgangers we know about
for sure are Coopers and the arms Mike
and Bob are different things you know I
mean so do they have doppelgangers I
don't know with Leland have one he's up
there it's very unclear I hope we find
out more about this I know that there
was some rumors at least that everyone
was going to have a doppelganger in the
original idea for season 3 and I'm sort
of hoping that 25 years later they
decided that was a bad idea
but we won't know until we know last
question where I look at today is no
comment about 119 so this refers to the
Tweaker that we saw across the street
from the house where dougie and Jade
were she says the number 119 and
honestly I just don't know what was
going on there it's a superior mystery
at this point what we do know about that
scene is that she's definitely doing
drugs it appeared to me that she was on
meth and then she was taking some pills
probably to come down I've read that the
119 could be related to the number of
pills like she was counting out how many
she was taking as in committing suicide
I didn't get that necessarily her son
looks out the window and sees the man
put the bomb of the tracker on Dougie's
car but as of now dougies car is just
sitting there anyway so I have a feeling
that something about this is important I
just don't know where to start so you
guys tell me in the comments what you
think about all these questions and
answers if there were any answers it's
it's fun to speculate but let's not get
crazy about thinking we can figure
everything out let's enjoy the ride and
I'll be doing the Q&A for part 4 really
soon I'm going to be working on it right
out
this get ready for part 5 recap and
review so please subscribe to my channel
and like the video if you enjoyed it
join the conversation I'd like I like
looking at these questions after the
fact and I like answering them all so
thanks for all the positive feedback you
guys have been giving in the last week I
appreciate it and I hope to be coming
out with new stuff at a regular pace
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon